how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about old things
Marvel and everything relating to the
MCU now sadly most of Marvel Studios as
projects both movies and shows that are
upcoming have been put on hold due to
the coronavirus however some of these
projects have been working remotely
Marvel Studios has already had to
reschedule and rearrange phase four of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe but
they're doing everything that they can
to stick to this new schedule and a lot
of projects have actually been able to
get some work done and shang-chi and The
Legend of the ten rings happens to be
one of those projects and last night we
actually got some considerable details
about the show including what the main
plot is going to be and the powers that
shang-chi will have in the film and for
those of you who may not be that excited
about shang-chi and the legend of the
ten rings it sounds like some mutants
may show up in the film and it also
sounds like Shane she was secretly in
the background the whole entire time in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe and we
also do have some casting news as well
so we'll break down every single thing
that we know about shang-chi and the
legend of the ten rings if you're new be
sure to subscribe for your Marvel
content and also so you can enter my
Iron Man Funko pop giveaway this week
all you have to do to enter is subscribe
like the video and comment down below
with your thoughts on the subject
so today's shang-chi and the legend of
deterrence plot details come from fandom
of wire they are the ones who got the
exclusive details about this and posted
them to their site and we learn a lot
from these new details including a lot
about the movie and these details even
match up with a previous plot leak that
we got from a very reputable source in
the past and of course I'll be sure to
talk about that in this video quick
spoiler alert for anybody who is trying
to avoid any and all things about
shang-chi and the legend of the ten
rings if you're with me let's dive into
the plot in this film shang-chi will
have a special power and because of it
he was raised in an orphanage for kids
that are trained to fight this special
orphanage is run by the Mandarin and
before we go on no I'm not talking about
that fake Mandarin that we saw in Iron
Man 3 hey bloody hell bloody hell don't
I'm not moving you want something take
it
although the guns are all fake cuz those
wankers wouldn't trust me with the real
ones what
shang-chi would eventually go on to
somehow escape the school slash prison
and begins to live life on the run and
he goes through his entire life trying
to avoid and stay out of the clutches of
the Mandarin
however despite shengqi's best efforts
the Mandarin does eventually find the
grown-up shang-chi again and he has an
offer for him and this offer is a chance
the Mandarin promises shang-chi money
and power along with the promise that
he'll finally stop chasing him if he
will fight in an epic and magical
tournament that every kid in the
orphanage has been training for their
entire lives whoever wins this
tournament gets the legendary ten rings
which grants the user even more power
which clearly the Mandarin wants however
the Mandarin is currently too old to
fight so he enlists shang-chi now
according to fandom wire this tournament
that shang-chi is going to be fighting
in for the Mandarin is going to have new
characters from all corners of the MCU
that include Wizards aliens fighters and
well-known comic book characters that we
haven't seen before and this is
essentially going to be a mortal kombat
but a Marvel version of it and we
actually know who these characters are
going to be but first let's talk about
Shang cheese special power according to
fandom wire in this film Shang cheese
special power is going to be the ability
to clone himself while fighting now this
is actually an ability that shang-chi
has in the comics to a certain extent in
the comics shang-chi can create clones
of himself anytime anywhere for any type
of reason he could create a clone to
simply make dinner for him so he
wouldn't have to make it himself but
according to this report his powers are
going to be a little bit different in
the MCU according to this report his
powers and the MCU are going to be kind
of limited in the film he's only going
to be able to project versions of
himself during fight sequences meaning
he's only going to be able to clone
himself while he's fighting although
this kind of nerfs his power it doesn't
really nerf it all that much because he
can still use it for combat
now fandom wire says that they asked
their source who provided them this
information what the fighting and
cloning is going to be like they asked
their sources if the film's combat is
going to be more like the movie the raid
as far as hand-to-hand combat is
concerned or if it's going to be more of
a sort of magical fighting sing quits
over using the cloning effect and their
sources told them that it's going to be
a mess
of both now one thing that's very
interesting about this report is that it
does mention the fact that Marvel
Studios knows that fans are very upset
over the mandarins betrayal in Iron Man
3 in the movie the Mandarin ended up
being a fake and not the real Mandarin
that we knew from the comics and the ten
rings weren't even really in the movie
not the true ten rings at least and the
report says without spoiling anything
they do address this in the film
so hopefully Marvel Studios will provide
some sort of retribution for Iron Man 3
now here's the kicker about these plot
details they tied directly into some
other plot details that came to surface
not too long ago and the plot leaked
details were pretty much exactly as I
just described but they mentioned
characters specifically some of the
characters that are going to be in the
tournament now all of these characters
are going to be fighting to win the ten
rings now for those of you who are not
familiar with what the mandarins ten
rings of power are I'll explain because
they are very very powerful each
individual ring on each individual
finger holds a very specific power on
the left hand the pinky finger is ice
blast it freezes the air in its path and
can lower an object's temperature to
almost zero the ring finger is a Minto
intensifier it magnifies the Mandarin
psychic energy enabling him to mentally
control a person although it's only
effective at a short range the middle
finger is electro blossom ending
quantities of electrical energy
determined by the where the index finger
is flame blasts it emits infrared
radiation it can cause air to in
condense by igniting its molecules and
the thumb on the left hand is white
light and many many different types of
energy frequently used as laser beams
now on the right hand the pinky finger
is black light it creates areas of
absolute darkness where all light is
absorbed and it's believed to access the
dark force the ring finger is a dis
integration beam it destroys bonds
between atoms and molecules causing an
object's cohesion to fall apart but it
needs twenty minutes recharge time
between uses the middle finger is a
vortex beam the user can create vortexes
and levitate objects and even himself
the index finger is an impact beam it
projects concussive force of
approximately 350 pounds of TNT and the
thumb on the right hand is a matter
rearranger it can rearrange atoms
or molecules of substances or speed up
or slow down their movements so as you
can see they are extremely powerful
objects when used together now the plot
details say that this is going to be an
alien device so it's not going to be
from Earth and many people are going to
compete for it in the tournament and
here's what the league has to say about
these characters it says that shang-chi
enters a kung-fu tournament in which the
prize is the legendary ten rings an
ancient alien artifact that has been
protected for centuries the other
fighters that are going to be in this
tournament are a variety of D and C list
Marvel characters other characters that
are going to be entered into the
tournament are going to be mutant
characters and this league states that
it's not sure if these will be the
introduction of the mutants to the MCU
but mutants that are known to appear in
this will be spiral Omega red and T ray
now by the time shang-chi and The Legend
of the ten rings comes out it sounds
like there are going to be other mutants
introduced into the MCU beforehand and
based off of the description of
shengqi's power in the movie it sounds
like he may even be a mutant himself
even though that's not necessarily what
he was in the comics now the mutants
that are said to be in the movie that
are going to be competing in the
tournament all have some things in
common they're all extremely gifted at
hand-to-hand combat with a few other
abilities at it as well
for example spiral has multiple arms she
also has enhanced strength she has the
ability of flight telepathy and she is
skilled in sorcery Omega Red is also
very skilled in hand-to-hand combat and
also has superhuman strength speed
agility stamina and reflexes but also
has carbonadium retractable tentacles in
each of his arms so kind of like
scorpion from Mortal Kombat but he can
also self heal like Wolverine or
Deadpool making him a very fierce
competitor in this tournament and then T
ray is actually an arch enemy of
Deadpool in the comics he's somewhat of
a zombie and has vast knowledge of
magical voodoo rituals and as the report
said there are going to be some magical
aspects to the fighting that we're going
to see but here's where it gets really
interesting a leak says that Baron Mordo
is also going to be entering the
tournament because he seeks the ten
rings for his own purposes now I think
that everybody knew that Baron Mordo was
going to come back he was set up quite
nicely to be the next villain of the
next Doctor Strange film in the
credit scene for dr. strange now when we
left him he had decided that there were
too many sorcerers in the world and he
took it upon himself to start
eliminating them however he would have
had to realize that dr. strange is not
going to be an easy opponent in fact the
ancient one in Avengers endgame revealed
that dr. strange was supposed to be the
best of them she went forward in time
and saw what he would become and since
more dough before dr. strange was her
right-hand man it's more than likely she
revealed that information to him so
Mordor knows that he's not going to be
able to easily defeat dr. strange
especially if he's been keeping up with
the events that have been happening in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe dr.
strange played a very important role in
defeating Thanos so he's most likely
going to be trying to get the tin ring
so he can eliminate dr. strange and the
rest of the sorcerers now to top it all
off this report says that aquafina is
going to be playing a follow sweet in
the comics she is shang-chi sister but
in this new updated version of the story
she is going to be playing the mandarins
daughter and then Tony chih-wei Leung is
going to be playing the Mandarin so let
me know what you all think about this
does this sound like an exciting story
for shang-chi and the legend of the ten
rings be sure to let me know what you
think in the comments down below don't
forget to leave a like on the video and
subscribe to stay up to date on
everything relating to the MCU for live
updates you can follow me on Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof